mourning the victims and searching for
answers in christchurch
outside the city's al-nur mosque people
paused
to honor those who lost their lives in
the worst mass
murder in new zealand's modern history
these were the scenes friday as a
suspected white supremacist
opened fire on worshipers at el nor and
at a mosque in the neighborhood of
linwood
killing and wounding dozens as police
scrambled to stop the shooter rescuers
raced to save the wounded
survivors spoke of a narrow escape
after three four minutes we hired you
know the
firing and it was from the main entrance
the main entrance of the building and
then everybody
just run towards the back doors just to
save themselves
and first we hide behind the cars and
you know
under the cars and then when we see that
firing still on we try to
you know jump the fence this footage
shows the moment police
apprehended the suspect after forcing
his car
off the road they brought an end to the
rampage
the suspected shooter is 28 year old
australian brenton tarrant
charged with murder he appeared for the
first time in court on saturday
and was remanded to custody until april
5th
investigators say he published a racist
anti-immigrant manifesto online
before carrying out the massacre the
prime minister
vowed to tighten the country's gun laws
after it was revealed
terrence had a license to carry the
types of guns used in the attack
while work has been done as to the chain
of events that led to both the holding
of this gun license
and the possession of these weapons i
can tell you one thing right now
our gun laws will change
new zealand's terror alert level was
raised from low to high in the wake of
the attack
with added security around the country's
mosques
dozens of the wounded remain
hospitalized some of whom are still
fighting for their lives
okay for more on this let's cross over
to claire richardson who is in
christchurch
claire the suspected gunman um has
already appeared in court he's been
charged with murder
what do we know about him and what is
likely to happen to him now
that's right he appeared in court today
very
quickly indeed but apparently that is
typical in a new zealand proceeding like
this
uh he's going to be held until april 5th
when he will be on
trial again currently facing one count
of murder although the judge has said
that you can suspect to see many more
tacked on to that later
the key thing to know about this
individual is in fact that he is
believed to be the man who posted a
rambling manifesto online in which he
expressed his dislike of
multiculturalism and
immigration in new zealand two things
that the cult that the country
really values uh in addition to
expressing his support for white
nationalist leaders
so you can imagine that is very
troubling indeed to the people who are
grieving here today
new zealand's prime minister jacinda
ardern has promised
very clearly that new zealand's gun gun
laws
will change is this controversial in way
in any way will this be
supported by new zealanders
well there are many saying she will need
to act quickly to impose any reforms
while emotions are still running high at
this moment she did say earlier today
that there would be some gun control
imposed we later heard the attorney
general
take it a step further saying that he
would ban semi-automatic weapons
later walked that back a little bit to
say he didn't want to get too far ahead
of the prime minister's wishes
but around here today in christchurch
there's a very clear appetite
for something to have been done there
are a lot of questions being asked about
how
a man like the key suspect could legally
have possessed
five firearms including two
semi-automatic weapons
given the country's current laws okay so
a lot of questions being asked
describe the atmosphere for us uh where
you
are how are people in christchurch in
new zealand
coping
well you can imagine that this is a very
dark day
after many people were in lockdown
throughout the day yesterday either in
hospitals or in classrooms
this was the first time that people were
able to come out and grieve together and
earlier today it was a beautiful sunny
day out a typical day when you might
imagine people would be having weekend
picnics
instead events were cancelled and
makeshift memorials like the one i'm
standing in front of right now have
sprung up around the city
where people have been laying down
flowers and teddy bears and messages of
solidarity
to their muslim communities saying that
this should not have happened to you in
a country like new zealand where there's
freedom of religion
and we are so sorry and are going to
work together to try and prevent
something like this from happening again
all right claire richardson in
christchurch thank you so much for your
reporting
you